[Music]
around 11 59 a.d a mathematician called
baskara the learned sketched a design
for a wheel containing curved reservoirs
of mercury
he reasoned that as the wheels spun the
mercury would flow to the bottom of each
reservoir leaving one side of the wheel
perpetually heavier than the other the
imbalance would keep the wheel turning
forever
baskara's drawing was one of the
earliest designs for a perpetual motion
machine
a device that can do work indefinitely
without any external energy source
imagine a windmill that produced the
breeze it needed to keep rotating
or a light bulb whose glow provided its
own electricity
these devices have captured many
inventors imaginations because they
could transform our relationship with
energy
for example if you could build a
perpetual motion machine that included
humans as part of its perfectly
efficient system it could sustain life
indefinitely
there's just one problem
they don't work
ideas for perpetual motion machines all
violate one or more fundamental laws of
thermodynamics the branch of physics
that describes the relationship between
different forms of energy
the first law of thermodynamics says
that energy can't be created or
destroyed you can't get out more energy
than you put in
that rules out a useful perpetual motion
machine right away because a machine
could only ever produce as much energy
as it consumed
there wouldn't be any left over to power
a car or charge a phone
but what if you just wanted the machine
to keep itself moving
inventors have proposed plenty of ideas
several of these have been variations on
baskara's overbalanced wheel with
rolling balls or weights on swinging
arms
none of them work the moving parts that
make one side of the wheel heavier also
shift its center of mass downward below
the axle
with a low center of mass the wheel just
swings back and forth like a pendulum
then stops
what about a different approach
in the 17th century robert boyle came up
with an idea for a self-watering pot
he theorized that capillary action the
attraction between liquids and surfaces
that pulls water through thin tubes
might keep the water cycling around the
bowl
but if the capillary action is strong
enough to overcome gravity and draw the
water up it would also prevent it from
falling back into the bowl
then there are versions with magnets
like this set of ramps
the ball is supposed to be pulled
upwards by the magnet at the top fall
back down through the hole and repeat
the cycle
this one fails because like the
self-watering pot the magnet would
simply hold the ball at the top even if
it somehow did keep moving the magnet's
strength would degrade over time and
eventually stop working
for each of these machines to keep
moving they'd have to create some extra
energy to nudge the system past its
stopping point
breaking the first law of thermodynamics
there are ones that seem to keep going
but in reality they invariably turn out
to be drawing energy from some external
source
even if engineers could somehow design a
machine that didn't violate the first
law of thermodynamics it still wouldn't
work in the real world because of the
second law
the second law of thermodynamics tells
us that energy tends to spread out
through processes like friction
any real machine would have moving parts
or interactions with air or liquid
molecules that would generate tiny
amounts of friction and heat even in a
vacuum that heat is energy escaping and
it would keep leeching out reducing the
energy available to move the system
itself until the machine inevitably
stopped
so far these two laws of thermodynamics
have stymied every idea for perpetual
motion and the dreams of perfectly
efficient energy generation they imply
yet it's hard to conclusively say we'll
never discover a perpetual motion
machine because there's still so much we
don't understand about the universe
perhaps we'll find new exotic forms of
matter that'll force us to revisit the
laws of thermodynamics
or maybe there's perpetual motion on
tiny quantum scales
what we can be reasonably sure about is
that we'll never stop looking
for now the one thing that seems truly
perpetual is our search
[Music]
you